lo que he dibujado aquí en amarillo es
una línea digamos que sabemos dos cosas
de esta línea sabemos que tiene una
pendiente m y sabemos también que el
punto y coma de esta en esta línea por
lo que la pregunta que trataremos de
resolver es podemos fácilmente obtener
una ecuación para esta línea utilizando
esta información así que vamos a
intentarlo
todo punto en esta línea o todo x
en esta línea tiene que satisfacer la
condición de que la pendiente entre ese
punto y y digamos que este es un punto x
que es un punto arbitrario en la línea
el hecho de que esté en la línea nos
dice que la pendiente entre a b y x como
ayer debe de ser igual a m
así que utilicemos ese conocimiento para
hacer una ecuación
entonces cuál es la pendiente entre v y
x como nuestro cambio en y recuerda que
la pendiente es sólo el cambio en g
entre el cambio en x déjame escribir eso
la
tienen
es igual
al cambio
y
/ el cambio en x este pequeño triángulo
es la letra griega delta símbolo para el
cambio nuestro cambio en g veamos si
empezamos en iguala
estamos empezando en y es igual a b y si
acabamos en igual a esta arbitraria de
aquí este cambio en de aquí va a ser que
menos b
sí
- me ve
y eso va a estar sobre nuestro cambio en
x y utilizando la misma lógica
empezamos en x igualada y terminamos en
x igual a esta x arbitraria sea cual sea
la x en donde estemos por lo que nuestro
cambio en x va a ser este punto final
- nuestro punto inicial -
y sabemos que esta es la pendiente entre
estos dos puntos
esa es la pendiente entre cualesquiera
dos puntos en esta línea y eso va a ser
igual a m entonces esto va a ser igual a
lo que hemos hecho aquí
lo que hemos hecho aquí es crear una
ecuación que describe esta línea
puede que esté en una forma en la que no
estén acostumbrados a ver pero está en
una ecuación que describe toda xy ya que
satisfaga esta ecuación de aquí estará
en esta línea porque toda xy que
satisfaga esto la pendiente entre esta
xy y este punto de aquí entre el punto
ave va a ser igual a m
así que vamos de hecho ahora a convertir
esto en formas que podamos reconocer más
fácil por lo que déjame pegar esto para
simplificar esta expresión un poco o por
lo menos para deshacernos de este x
menos a en el denominador
multipliquemos ambos lados por x menos a
entonces si multiplicamos ambos lados
por x menos
x menos en el lado izquierdo de la
ecuación x menos en la izquierda y x
menos a en la derecha x menos
en la derecha pondremos unos paréntesis
alrededor de ellas entonces vamos a
multiplicar en ambos lados por x menos a
el objetivo de eso es tener a x menos a
dividido entre x menos a lo que sólo va
a ser igual a 1
y en el lado derecho de la ecuación sólo
tenemos m por x menos así que todo esto
se simplifica a que menos ve ya menos
que es igual
es igual a m por x menos
y justo aquí está la forma que los
matemáticos han denominado como forma
punto pendiente así que esta de aquí es
la forma punto pendiente punto
de la ecuación que describe esta línea
ahora porque es llamada forma punto
pendiente bueno es muy fácil ver esto y
decir esta es la pendiente de la línea
en vez de esta es la pendiente de la
línea y puedo poner los dos puntos
adentro el punto y coma b está en esta
línea y la pendiente por x menos a es
igual a ieco mabe
veamos por qué es esto útil y por qué le
gusta a la gente utilizar este tipo de
cosas ya no hay que usar este ave y la
pendiente de m más hagamos esto un poco
más concreto digamos que tenemos
digamos que alguien te dijo que está
trabajando con una línea en la que la
pendiente es igual a 2 y va a través del
punto
y va a través del punto no sé
digamos que va a través del punto 7
negativo coma
7 negativo 5
entonces de una manera rápida puedes
utilizar esta información y tu
conocimiento en la forma punto pendiente
para escribir esto en esta forma podría
solo decir bueno una ecuación que
contenga este punto y que tenga esta
pendiente sería de menos b que 5 que
menos la componente en este punto
contenido por esta línea
es igual es igual a mi pendiente es
igual a mi pendiente x
por la equis menos la componente x que
contiene esta línea así que x menos
7 negativo
y solo como eso hemos escrito una
ecuación que tiene una pendiente de 2 y
que contiene este punto de aquí y si no
nos gusta esta x menos 7 negativo de
aquí podemos reescribir eso como x + 7
pero esta es la forma más cercana a la
forma punto pendiente
si quieres simplificar esto un poco
puedes escribir de menos 5 es igual a 2
por x + 7 puedes ver esto como una
manera de expresar la ecuación de esta
línea hay muchas más y con la que
estamos más familiarizados es la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen esto puede
convertirse fácilmente a la forma
pendiente ordenada al origen
para hacer eso nosotros sólo debemos
distribuir este 2 entonces tenemos de
menos 5 es igual
a 2 x x + 2 x 7 que es igual a 14 y
luego podemos quitar este 5 en la
izquierda al sumar 5 en ambos lados de
la ecuación y luego nos queda en el lado
izquierdo de la ecuación
y en el lado derecho de la ecuación 2 x
+ 19 por lo que esto de aquí está en la
forma de pendiente ordenada al origen
tienes aquí tu pendiente y tu ordenada
al origen entonces esta es la forma de
bien
está
al
origen
y esta de aquí es la forma punto
pendiente